[Musique]
terrible bilan des inondations pour
l'instant 21 morts 10 disparus de
nouveaux corps viennent d'être retrouvés
à ramon dans le gard où une digue s'est
rompue la nuit dernière l'heure des
premiers bilans avec la décrue des
milliers de sinistrés plus de 40 mille
foyers privés d'électricité
le gouvernement débloque un fonds
d'urgence de 10 millions d'euros
dans certaines communes des centaines
d'habitants sont encore privées d'eau
courante
page spéciale le consacrée aux
cérémonies du 11 septembre et nous vous
retrouvons en direct de new york david
pujadas dans une demi heure une dernière
information béatrice il y a deux heures
l'alerté terroriste a été relevé au
niveau 4 le maximum est de 5
c'est dire que ces commémorations risque
de se dérouler dans un climat assez
tendu à tout à l'heure à tout l art aux
alentours de 20h30 madame monsieur
bonsoir je vous le dise en titre
le bilan des victimes s'est terriblement
alourdie depuis hier soir à l'heure
qu'il est au moins 21 personnes sont
mortes et 10 portés disparus d'un côté
la décrue permettent aux sauveteurs de
découvrir de nouveaux corps de l'autre
toujours dans le gard si lourdement
touchée c'est la rupture d'une digue
pendant la nuit qui a projeté une
immense vague meurtrière sur le village
d'aramon deux nouveaux corps viennent
d'être repêché pour portage nathalie
jourdan virgilia d'eau enfin la terre
ferme
pourquoi
une personne évacuée une de plus des
allers retours incessants depuis la nuit
dernière les sauveteurs ne quittent pas
leur embarcation réfugiés à l'étagé
certains habitants n'arrivent pas à se
résigner à 89 ans étienne refuse de
quitter sa maison
j'étais toujours ma yan tu nous fais
façon une fois de plus je fais face mais
quand même ça dure il ya aussi les
autres ce dont on est sans nouvelles et
qui faut localiser dans des rues
transformées en cas nous le 96 en fait
de cette rue des 97 alors aramon cité
lacustre 100 numéros sans repère un
labyrinthe pour des pompiers souvent
venus d'ailleurs en renfort en une nuit
c'est tout un village qui s'est
éparpillé difficile de savoir qui
étouffe la mairie à afficher une liste
des personnes qui se sont signalées a
été évacué ah oui beaucoup ouvrent en
est sûre ce soir les sauveteurs ont
encore une trentaine de personnes à
retrouver les reconnaissances vont
continuer avec un espoir que le bilan ne
s'alourdisse pas quatre corps ont déjà
été repêchés
et pour mieux mesurer l'ampleur du
déluge qui a touché le gard et le
vaucluse depuis hier soir je vous
propose de regarder ses vidéos amateur
filmée sur le vif clichés instantanés
notamment dans la région d'alès où les
plus chanceux ont réussi à s'en sortir
sans trop de dommages loïc de la mornais
pierre bande joseph au pied des barres
d'immeubles legras vieux un affluent du
gardon est devenue une mer en furie
du haut de son balcon un habitant film
cette peugeot 205 qui semble en sursis
au loin une caravane est emporté
quelques silhouettes se hasarde dans les
rues sous une pluie diluvienne et quand
notre caméraman amateur revient sur la
peugeot le clou là déjà retourné
aujourd'hui voici ce que la crue a
laissé derrière elle à quelques
kilomètres au sud d'alès des voitures
sont empilés comme à la casse c'est
comme si l'eau avait pris plaisir à
jouer avec les règles les plus
élémentaires de l'urbanisme sur la même
route un peu plus loin un car s'est
renversé sur la chaussée
ses occupants un groupe de touristes
allemands reviennent de loin
hébergée la nuit dernière dans un
gymnase ils ont découvert ce matin les
images de leur aventure
nous avons dû puiser les vitres pour
sortir du car nous étions bloqués à
l'intérieur l'eau montait c'est
effrayant qui nous avons aperçu une
maison alors nous avons défoncé les
portes du rez-de-chaussée compte parmi
les quarante cinq touristes allemands
ont même utilisé les rideaux du bus pour
faire une ligne de vie et nagé jusqu'à
la maison la plus proche
c'est cette femme et son mari qui grâce
à leurs balcons émergé ont pu les sauver
on a fait monter 3 et mon mari avait des
trains ont compté les monter tous par là
pour éviter d'ouvrir un bas pour que
l'eau monte monte pas au premier étage
les bornes les gens étaient tellement
épuisée dans l'automobile il y avait
déjà les personnages jouent ce soir le
gymnase d'alès devrait accueillir pour
la seconde nuit de nouveaux sinistrés
qui ont tout perdu dans les inondations
parmi les victimes un pompier de 43 ans
a succombé à ses blessures hier
après-midi un comportement exemplaire un
homme de courage qui a perdu la vie en
portant secours à deux automobilistes
piégés dans leurs voitures karine
comazzi parce qu'elle pense c'était son
camion préférer les collègues de
dominique barascud ont choisi de venir
le garer devant chez lui un hommage muet
d'hommes
habitué à agir à servir dimanche
dominique a sorti de l'eau deux
automobilistes avant d'être aspiré par
un tourbillon sa tête percute un arbre
massage cardiaque sur le camion le coeur
redémarre mais dominique décède lundi
après midi
il est parti il tellement vite que il
était habillé on regardait un film la
télé ni ta vie en tee shirt et aussi
payer porter comme ça dont il est parti
à fond la caisse comme d'habitude
et voilà il est allé sur le terrain
c'était trois heures et demie puis je
n'ai plus revu pompier professionnel à
l'aéroport de montpellier dominique
servent et bénévolement depuis 21 ans à
la caserne de saint mathieu de tréviers
sa compagne décrit au présent un homme
passionné généreuse qui souhaitait
c'était mort et en intervention donc
quelque part je me dis qu'il a été
exaucé parce qu'il est mort avec les
bottes de pompiers je savais qu'il était
pompier quand je l' ai connu donc je
savais les risques que je savais
l'emploi du temps donc super maman je
faisais d'accepter tout ça oui oui
tenues par leur devoir de réserve les
camarades de dominique ont passé leur
tristesse en nettoyant leur tenue le
geste sur l'esprit absent hier je
comprenais pas pourquoi c'était sauver
ou périr et que là c'était sauver et
période c'est une belle devise mais
tellement cruel
gérard saumade c'est vrai que c'est une
devise cruel vous êtes donc le maire de
saint mathieu de tréviers vous ne
pouvait que rendre hommage comme n'a à
ce pompier qui était un homme de devoir
bien sûr je suis rouge avait d'ailleurs
les pompiers à l'heure actuelle chez
vraiment chaud qui sont à la base du
service de la sécurité publique et je
crois que c'est très important en
lâchant pas content c'est souvent ce
sont des hommes de devoir et lui hérité
en particulier se sont pas des rambo ce
sont des gens qui ont un métier un
métier qui devient à l'heure actuelle de
plus en plus important ce ne sont pas
simplement de soldats du feu mais
cherchent eux qui assurent la sécurité
de tous les français
je crois qu'il faut une pensée et il
faut éviter en particulier
de les amener dans les difficultés
je comparais son rôle rôle des guides de
haute montagne qui vont chercher des
gens qui font déjà brûlant balaj est
pareil ce soir oui et ce soir c'est
toute la famille des pompiers qui est
particulièrement touché dans votre
commune et nageurs bien cher bien sûr je
suis le groupe voire de chamakh retrait
jade et a eu quatre bornes 80 jaillir au
combat quand on mord en service commandé
depuis elle en 20 ans y compris
d'ailleurs le père du chef du groupement
actuelle dont c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup on être mort sur un village qui
a 88 ans maintenant un dernier mot les
solidarités jouera forcément oui bien
sûr
gageure bien sûr vous savez ce soir on
va réunir avec le conseil municipal on
va réunir tous les pompiers des hommes
et des femmes et j'ai vu tout à l'heure
encore des garçons et des filles qui
pleurait qui pleurait parce que leurs
copains étaient tombés moi je voudrais
dire au champ d'honneur
merci monsieur d'avoir à témoigner en
direct dans ce journal
l'heure est au premier bilan les
inondations qui ont ravagé le sud est de
la france laisse démunis des milliers
d'habitants 150 minimes téléphoniques
sont coupées depuis hier et à bagnols
sur cèze dans le gard c'est un
transformateur qui a été noyée sous les
eaux la vie tente de s'organiser tant
bien que mal
yasmina farber et patrice verchère
asphyxié paralysé bagnols sur cèze
respire enfin depuis la décrue l'eau a
quitté le quartier de la rue de l'europe
laissant derrière elle des habitants
désemparés silencieux par la force des
choses pendant les intempéries
certains peuvent dire aujourd'hui qu'ils
se sentent abandonnés
où a été remise d'être éternellement on
n'a pas eu une seule façon de la mairie
les pompiers de personnes devant kirikou
pcv sinon personne ne peut ressentir ça
ne comprends pas bon moi je vous propose
le faire en sens unique à la fois pour
les piétons et pourquoi que le maire est
pourtant sur le conte depuis ce matin sa
ville était coupée en deux il a fallu
rétablir un semblant de circulation
difficile d'informer les 20000 habitants
de la commune en temps réel pendant la
crue tous les services ont été débordés
on peut toujours trouver des carences
mais je crois que la crue était
tellement brutale les avis de crue aussi
nous ont un peu pris de vitesse c'est à
dire que nous avions des informations
qui étaient décalés par rapport à la
réalité innodb les chiffres il était
déjà dépassée dans la réalité et ça
aussi ça nous a gênés dans la gestion de
la crise
pas de liaison radio pas de réseau
téléphonique un vrai casse tête pour la
cellule de crise de la mairie rez
sollicité ce sont les familles qui
actuellement recherche les parents ou
les enfants et les gens sont
particulièrement angoissée c'est vrai
qu'on sait pas toujours répond avec la
réouverture des routes des renforts des
alpes-maritimes ont enfin pu accéder à
bagnols sur cèze dans la nuit la commune
se sent moins seul pour affronter une
crise qui a épuisé les troupes orange
maintenant la ville isolée par les eaux
retrouve peu à peu ses voies de
communication et le retour du beau temps
permet à chacun d'évaluer les dégâts et
de commencer à nettoyer leur rendit
benoît gadret tant pis pour les quarts
aux anciens il faut les cas c'est pour
évacuer l'eau de cet appartement
si l'eau est rentrée en masse la
propriétaire une retraitée ne s'en remet
toujours toi je dors pas la nuit je mens
je ne partais le mans c'est vrai j'y
arrive pas mal et je suis vraiment
profile au pire des intempéries cette
rue d'orange est devenu un véritable
torrent et certains dégâts causés par
l'eau seront difficiles à réparer la
cuve à fuel il par exemple les vols qui
a fui voilà là cela qu elle espérait
bien elle est perdue il faut d'abord la
vidanger et la nettoyer et repartir
sainement c'est comme avec touches et
avoir vous combler c'est une mélange
quelque chose de personnel
le son est content lada retrouvées à
quelques kilomètres de là piolenc la
commune elle aussi a été dévasté si le
mauvais sort s'est acharné sur marie la
semaine dernière c'est son choix qui
fuyaient après un orage
ça a coulé par le toit fouet la semaine
dernière semaine alors cette semaine a
été convenu que le monde et l'inondation
dehors alors ça c'est clairement fait
deux en même temps essayer de trouver
les pompiers ils doivent être au tour
heureusement la solidarité joue à plein
ses employés municipaux par exemple sont
venus spontanément d'une autre commune
du vaucluse
juste pour aider à nettoyer jean pierre
raffarin s'est rendu sur place ce matin
et a pu évaluer lui-même l'ampleur de la
catastrophe en survolant les zones les
plus touchées l'a aussitôt annoncé le
déblocage d'urgence d'un fonds de 10
millions d'euros faire unique sainte
olive benoît jourdain
ce matin l'image du premier ministre
atterré devant l'ampleur du désastre
jean pierre raffarin a décidé de
rejoindre dans le gard nicolas sarkozy
le premier à être allé témoigner sur
place la solidarité nationale jusqu'à la
barousse et le patron des champions a
été mitraillé les pompiers à sommières
c'est la désolation
les habitants épuisés s'acharne comme
ils peuvent avec les moyens du bord mais
beaucoup ont le sentiment d'être
abandonnés et la colère éclate
moreno musicaux comme quoi vivent non
plus
d'accord on fait une bonne job vous avez
la difficulté tout ça mais c'est une
crise très violente
on va trouver les moyens matériels il ya
de la vie il va remettre la ville
appelant si jean-pierre à part ainsi
trouver les gestes
le premier ministre a eu du mal à
convaincre les sinistrés et les élus que
cette fois cela serait différent qu une
vraie réflexion elle était engagée pour
mettre en place les équipements
nécessaires et éviter en amont ce type
de catastrophe
pour l'instant jean pierre raffarin à
débloquer une première enveloppe
d'urgence 10 millions d'euros le déluge
dans le sud-est n'aura rien épargné sur
son passage ni les troupeaux ni les
cultures et c'est toute l'activité d'une
région qui est meurtri avec à chaque
fois des hommes qui ont perdu le labeur
de toute une vie yannick à rossi benin
jourdain le pinard son bail avec lui des
années de labeur et d'investissement ces
deux viticulteurs réussi cet après midi
à ouvrir la coopérative
l'eau est enfin descendre du gala voici
je n'ai plus de 6,5 en remerciant au
passage en même temps dans ces trucs
dans la cave de dion s'il n'y a
quasiment plus rien d'un tact ce qui est
informatique sur le pays tout est
informatisé
je ne peux marcher possible commerce et
du big one
l'eau est montée jusqu'à plus de 8
mètres du d'en haut le spectacle est
saisissant
les invendus de la récolte passé les
fruits des premières vendanges précoces
tout est perdu dans cette cave qui
produit 20 mille hectolitres par les
vendanges devait commencer dans quelques
jours
il faudra attendre que ça sèche avant de
récolter à coup sûr pour rien tout
éliminer tel un diable dans la remorque
qui sert d'habitude pour le raisin on
entasse les déchets dans les villages et
ses viticulteurs la crue est une
catastrophe
déjà que la situation était très très
grave au niveau de la mévente sur cette
année là c'est en plus il n'y a pas de
récolte ça va poser d'énormes problèmes
financiers pour le premier exploitant
des problèmes graves dans tous les
départements d'après les premières
estimations la moitié du vignoble
gardois et endommagées ou détruites et
la feria des vendanges prévue jeudi
prochain été purement et simplement
annuler elle devait se dérouler à nîmes
dès hier nous évoquions les orages
cévenol provoquée par l la différence de
température entre la méditerranée et la
terre phénomènes climatiques
relativement fréquents dans le sud de la
france mais cette fois ci les crues ont
été particulièrement violentes
explications agnès monter ce film et
elle
autant d'eau en 24 heures que sur paris
en une année bien sûr dans le gard on a
l'habitude des orages à cette saison
mais à ce point c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
météo france avait prévu c'est lui qu'on
appelle ici phénomène cévenol elle se
répète tous les ans à la fin de l'été le
continent refroidi alors plus vite que
la mer dimanche il y avait une
différence de 10 degrés entre
l'intérieur des terres et la
méditerranée
des nuages lourds et chauds sont attirés
vers les terres poussé par des vents
marins au niveau des contreforts des
cévennes
ils sortent un front froid les orages se
succèdent les pluies sont diluviennes il
a fallu attendre longtemps avant que les
vents ne s'inverse ne renvoie les nuages
vers la mer ce qui s'est passé cette
fois-ci c'est que le phénomène est resté
stationnaire sur la même région pendant
24 heures
comme sous ces nuages d'orage il pleut
de façon diluviennes donc quand il pleut
pendant 24 heures on arrive à des cumuls
d'eau qui sont tout à fait exceptionnel
par sa taille
le nuage était lui aussi exceptionnel
plus gros qu'un département ces trombes
d'eau se sont engouffrés dans les
rivières étroites et pentues des
montagnes une géographie spécifique qui
rend les crues du sud est
particulièrement rapide et violente
le fonds d'urgence débloquée par jean
pierre apparaît n'est là que pour aider
au plus vite les sinistrés mais après
les situations d'urgence il faudra
reconstruire
comment les assurances fonctionnent tels
le régime de catastrophe naturelle n'a
pas encore été officiellement déclaré
david beeri le rendiez syrie paquet
depuis ce matin ce cabinet d'assurances
du centre ville d'orange ne désemplit
pas de nombreux clients viennent se
renseigner et certains commencent déjà à
dresser la longue liste des dégâts
j'ai des nouvelles de toute façon je
vous rappelle le mobile se mange plus on
est nous inonder de coups de téléphone
voilà comprend les messages on prend en
note tous les appels
on essaye de
mais de réconforter les clients en leur
disant de faire le maximum déjà pour
nettoyer nettoyer et prendre les
premières mesures d'urgence pour éviter
une aggravation des dommages sans
oublier de contacter rapidement son
assureur en attendant la visite d'un
expert
il est vivement conseillé de rassembler
toutes les preuves du sinistre
recueillir tout ce qui permettra à
l'assureur d'évaluer complètement et
rapidement le dommage par exemple des
factures des photos des vidéos des
témoignages tout ce qui permettra une
indemnisation rapide et complète
mais avant de lancer toute procédure
d'indemnisation le gouvernement doit
d'abord déclaré l'état de catastrophe
naturelle par décret en conseil des
ministres les victimes auront alors dix
jours pour adresser leurs déclarations à
leur assurance
les indemnités devraient ensuite si tout
va bien être versée dans un délai de
trois mois
ces dernières années la france a connu
plusieurs inondations meurtrières on
garde tous en mémoire le drame de vaison
la romaine ou encore de nîmes
y at il une fatalité à ces déluges
climatiques quelles leçons
quels enseignements at on tiré depuis
tentative de réponse dalil wolfram il
avait plu toute la nuit sur le garder
trompe diluviennes puis à 7 heures du
matin ce 3 octobre 1988 10 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau boueuse déferlèrent
dans les rues de nîmes
résultat 50 mille sinistrés et neuf
morts après ce déluge
les images parlent d'elles-mêmes à
vaison-la-romaine la rivière ou weis des
chaînes le 22 septembre 1992
rien ne lui résiste car si l'on croit
bilan 37 morts emportés par ce torrent
de boue
parmi eux une majorité de campeurs même
scénario les 12 et 13 novembre 1999 dans
le sud-est des crues exceptionnelles
noir les départements de l'aude du tarn
des pyrénées orientales et de l'hérault
jamais ces régions n'avaient subi un tel
désastre
trente-quatre personnes périrent à cette
occasion et pourtant depuis sept ans des
plans de prévention des risques sont
mises en place
3300 communes sont déjà concernés ces
plans prescrivent les zones non
constructibles les contraintes de
hauteur les aménagements divers mais le
gouvernement envisage de prendre des
mesures encore plus strictes
d'ici la fin du mois avant de refermer
ce chapitre consacré aux inondations un
point pratique des axes de circulation à
nouveau praticable heure là c'est hélas
8 sont réouvertes dans les deux sens
l'autoroute a9 aussi mais certaines
sorties sont encore interdites les
routes nationales elles sont en revanche
plus touchées certaines restent encore
totalement inaccessible le reste de la
qualité avec cette nouvelle évasion à la
prison de ploemeur il s'agit de la
deuxième en moins d'une semaine le
détenu courent toujours les directeur de
la maison d'arrêt vient d'être limogé
par le garde des sceaux
jacques devaux miss univers après
l'échelle le camion la prison de
ploemeur multiplie les évasions
cette fois le détenu travaillé dans
l'atelier de la prison il lui a suffi de
se glisser dans un carton pour se faire
la belle un carton chargé à bord d'un
camion venu chercher du matériel
l'agent du contrôle ressasse est rentré
dans le camion à l'intérieur pour compte
pour faire le contrôle bon et est passé
entre les palettes mais évidemment il
n'a pas ouvert tous les cartons pour
voir si un détenu s'y cachaient dans le
camion est ressorti le personnel de la
prison est bien sûr sous le choc ils
parlent d'échec mais dénonce surtout une
nouvelle fois le manque de moyens pour
dire que comme une passoire ozil se
réclamant de sécurité manque de
personnel
je n'aurais conduire un problème quelque
part un problème dont la directrice de
ploemeur vient de faire les frais elle
est muté dans une autre prison pour le
reste
l'administration promet une fois encore
d'étudier au plus vite la situation et
d'apporter une réponse à la tente des
surveillants en grande bretagne celui
qui est accusé du double meurtre des
petites jessica est honni comparaissait
pour la première fois devant la justice
aujourd'hui à l'enlèvement et au meurtre
de deux fillettes il devra également
répondre de complicité d'entravé à la
justice
ian huntley est actuellement détenu dans
un hôpital psychiatrique dans une
semaine les médecins devront dire si oui
ou non il est apte à être jugé
une page médecine qui concerne les
causes éventuelles de la mort subite du
nourrisson toujours une énigme
en france on a dénombré 338,4 de décès
en 99 aujourd'hui une équipe de
chercheurs de l'institut pasteur
envisage un lien entre le tabagisme de
la mère et la mort subite du nourrisson
la nicotine absorbée par le foetus dans
le ventre de sa mère diminuerait ce
réflexe respiratoire nathalie sa peña et
jean françois mouney jour je me souviens
que j'ai fait ou j'ai fait mon test de
grossesse à la maison j'ai jeté
symboliquement mon paquet de cigarettes
en me disant que j'allais arrêter
pendant pendant toute la durée de mâcon
16 mai arrêter de fumer quand on est
enceinte n'est pas toujours aussi facile
frédéric enceinte de six mois a beaucoup
de mal années réduit un peu votre
consommation va rapport à la dernière
fois non plus alors vous en êtes à
combien une fois par mois cette fumeuse
très dépendante vient consulter la
tabacologue de la maternité
à partir du moment où je me suis rendu
compte que j'arrivais diminué de moi
même mais j'arrive à diminuer à un
paquet ce qui était loin d'être bien je
suis venu consulter très vite
une démarche que trop peu de fumeuses
enfin engage sans doute parce qu elles
méconnaissent ou minimise les
conséquences du tabac sur le foetus
quand on commence à poser des questions
très précises
sur est ce que ça donne un petit poids
de bébé ou est ce que ça peut donner la
mort subite du nourrisson est bien là
les femmes et ben ne savent pas car le
tabac est un des principaux facteurs
impliqués dans la mort subite du
nourrisson
le mécanisme vient d'être expliquée par
une nouvelle étude menée sur des souris
la nicotine perturbent le fonctionnement
de récepteurs qui sont importants pour
la respiration et la réaction des
veilles quand l'oxygène dans le sang
baisse il reste encore des morts subites
du nourrisson et il faut s'attaquer aux
premiers facteurs de risque qui est le
tabagisme pendant la grossesse
arrêter de fumer demande une vraie
détermination d'autant plus que les
femmes enceintes devront peut-être se
passer de patchs à la nicotine
au vu de cette dernière étude la suisse
depuis aujourd'hui fait partie de l'onu
elle compte préserver sa neutralité tout
en devenant le 190ème états membres de
l'organisation s'est pas restreint
d'hommes que la population mars dernier
s'est prononcé pour cette adhésion
refusé depuis tant d'années la suisse
qui depuis plus d'un demi-siècle siégea
le nu comme simple observateur tout de
suite place à notre édition spéciale en
direct de new york à la veille des
commémorations du 11 septembre où nous
vous retrouvons dali pujadas oui
béatrice avec d'abord une image sous nos
yeux à l'instant le chantier du world
trade center vient de s'arrêter et un
prêtre a dit une messe devant les
ouvriers rassemblés qui ont posé leur
casque vous le voyez sous le drapeau
américain
les hommes maintenant discute quelques
instants ils ont également pris des
photos nous sommes à quelques heures de
cette cérémonie de commémoration une
image et puis une information puisque je
vous le disais en ce début de journal
la tension est montée puisque l' alerte
terroriste a été placé au niveau 4 4 sur
c'est à dire un niveau très élevé des
menaces d'attentât aurait été détectée
par le fbi et on a appris à tout à
l'heure que le vice président dick
cheney avait été placée à l'abri en lieu
sûr voilà pour le contexte donc dans
quelques heures qu aura lieu cette
commémoration est ici même derrière moi
on mesure un peu mieux l'impact la main
arqués de ses attentats sur la ville
avec ses vues aériennes prises
d'hélicoptère on voit bien que le world
trade center n'est plus qu'un trou ou
payant un gigantesque vide au milieu de
la forêt de gratte ciels du quartier sud
de manhattan du quartier d'affaires de
manhattan
alors que reste-t-il de ces attentats un
an après on va évidemment évoqué des
histoires très émouvante on va parler
économie
on va parler libertés publiques avant ça
tout simplement comment le ground zero
comme on dit ici pas ce chantier du
world trade center se présente à celui
qui arrive à new york
regardez cette banderole qui borde le
chantier we will never forget est
nous n'oublierons jamais et regardez
juste derrière des centaines des
milliers de personnes se pressent chaque
jour pour apercevoir le chantier en fait
la mairie estime que 10 millions de
personnes auront fait le déplacement
pour venir voir lens 0 autant dire
qu'elle est en train de devenir une
attraction ce qui met les autorités un
peu mal à l'aise
pascal golomer que tristan le brasse ils
viennent pour voir par tous les moyens
voir derrière les grilles derrière les
ouvriers qui s'affairent jour et nuit
cet immense chantier qu'est devenue
grande 0 comme une lente procession la
foule piétine autour du site le plus
visité de new york aujourd'hui 10
millions de personnes depuis le mois de
septembre lieu de curiosité lieu de
pèlerinage pour moi c'est comme visiter
un cimetière
je voulais que les gamins voient ça
c'est une partie de notre histoire
une partie de l'histoire des états unis
on a un devoir à faire pour l'école sur
le world trade center il y à de
l'émotion de la tristesse la volonté de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
et un peu d'espoir aussi parfois le fait
que tous ces gens soient simplement
réunit aujourd'hui de voir tout le monde
rassemblé oui cela a quelque chose de
réconfortant de l'autre côté de la rue
ce sont les marchands du temple
ils n'étaient que quelques uns il ya six
mois ils sont aujourd'hui des dizaines
souvenirs t-shirt gadgets rien d'illégal
dans tout cela rien d'indécent non plus
vous diront les vendeurs il ya bien une
épicerie qui fait des affaires à côté je
vois pas la différence
et puis il ya ceux qui travaillaient
déjà dans le quartier avant le 11
septembre
ils sont revenus quelques jours quelques
semaines plus tard et vivent désormais
une étrange cohabitation
quand on sait que tant de gens sont
morts ici voir ce lieu devenir
l'attraction touristique avec tous ces
vendeurs c'est un peu pénible pour nous
la cohabitation va pourtant se prolonger
pendant plusieurs années le temps que le
quartier se reconstruise et tentent de
vivre à nouveau normalement
voilà il faut noter que l'ancien maire
de new york rudolph giuliani a jugé
déplacé inconvenante ce commerce du
souvenir alors il n'y a pas que ça à new
york
nous sommes ici dans l'un de ces
endroits où l'émotion qui avait forcé
l'admiration lors du 11-septembre
s'exprime encore à battery park au sud
de manhattan c'est la chorale yeux l'une
des principales cérémonies demain et
vous le voyez on met la dernière main
aux préparatifs on grave dans le marbre
les noms des policiers morts le
11-septembre qui s'ajoute à leur
collègue qui était mort dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions auparavant
et puis il y a juste à côté à cet
endroit où l'on vient encore aujourd'hui
à portée de tous les coins des états
unis un objet un insigne un casque tout
simplement un mot de compassion et où
l'on vient se recueillir un moment en
famille ou tout simplement observé enfin
il ya ceux qui ont souffert dans leur
chair et du 11 septembre
regardez cette photo c'est l'une des
plus connues de ce jour noir pour les
états unis cette femme s'appelle merci
borders
elle a 28 ans elle était secrétaire au
81e étage de la première tour celle qui
s'est effondré en premier
les commentateurs l'ont appelé la femme
de cendres cette femme nous l'avons
retrouvée pour elle la vie s'est arrêtée
ce jour du 11 septembre
cet art portage de jean-marc il ose et
de nice hawkins elle est ressortie
vivante du nuage de l'apocalypse et une
amérique réchappé les ténèbres a fait de
cette dame ne cendres l'une de ces
nouvelles icônes mais dans la tête de
l'élégante secrétaire de la bank of
america
quelque chose s'est arrêtée le 11
septembre 11 mois sans vouloir sortir de
sa banlieue à une heure de new york 11
mois sans quitter son studio du 4 109
avenue c'est marcy borders la dame de
cendres n'est plus que la prisonnière de
ses angoisses et de ses peurs
c'est la guerre toujours la guerre des
missiles des coups de feu aux shops des
bateaux de guerre et des avions
c'est toujours la guerre et pourtant
vous n'avez jamais vu ça je sais et
c'est ça qui me tracasse dehors je ne
sais pas vraiment pourquoi ça devient la
guerre c'est déjà pas mal que je ne me
retrouve pas quoi marcy n'a pas voulu du
nouveau job qu'on lui a proposé trop
angoissant de reprendre le métro
à défaut d'être membre d'une famille de
victimes elle fait aujourd'hui partie de
ces milliers de paume et du 11 septembre
oublié des institutions et dont
l'amérique découvre seulement l'immense
détresse psychologique
la première fois que je me suis rendu au
centre médical
la fim a bombardé de médicaments elle
n'a pas pris le temps de m'écouter de
comprendre par quoi je passais
l'évolution des symptômes 5 tout se
résumer à prenez sa vie jour prenez ça
me joue et revenez nous voir
à défaut de l'aide financière et
thérapeutiques qu'elle dit toujours
attendre
marcy borders rembourse aujourd'hui ses
dettes en monnayant pour quelques
centaines de dollars
son image arrêtée un 11 septembre son
image arrêtée deux dames de cendres
[Musique]
on se retrouve ici à l'église saint paul
c'est la plus vieille de la ville les
tours était juste à côté et par miracle
elle est restée intacte elle a accueilli
les secours et aujourd'hui vous le voyez
à ses grilles se sont transformées en un
autre lieu de retrouvailles pour ceux
qui viennent rendre hommage aux victimes
alors concernant les victimes la
municipalité vient de donner un nouveau
bilan elles sont au nombre de 2800 une
exactement le plus difficile souvent
pour leurs familles c'est qu'un grand
nombre d'entre elles n'ont pas été
formellement identifié voici l'histoire
d'une mère martine saada elle est
française son fils thierry avait 26 ans
il travaillait dans les tours depuis
trois mois seulement comme courtier et
indique en juin dernier qu'elle a appris
que son corps avait été formellement
identifiée grâce à l'adn
elle est arrivée hier pour assister aux
cérémonies nous étions avec elle cet art
portage de maryse burgot et
jean-françois revenus sa vie s'est
arrêtée là le 11 septembre 2001 il avait
26 ans une soeur et trois frères thierry
saada était l'aînée de la famille il
appelait tous les jours de son bureau du
105e étage
il racontait combien la vue était belle
de là haut et il promettait au petit
dernier qui le ferait venir un jour aux
états unis
il n'imaginait pas bien sûr que les
siens viendrait à new york pleurer sa
disparition et chercher quelque chose de
lui quelque part sur le chantier de
ground zero
comme il est doux j'ai jamais vu
c'est dans les médiations tout passe
là-dedans
ça nous touche beaucoup parce que en
tout cas c'est un endroit que notre fils
aille mais c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est l'endroit l'a rendu heureux et c
est important pour nous les saad à son
arrivée hier aux états unis pour
assister aux cérémonies
ils ont d'abord souhaité se rendre à
l'institut médico légal de new york
ici des experts en adn travaille encore
sur des milliers de fragments humains
pour identifier les victimes
monsieur saada préfère attendre dehors
il est insupportable pour lui comme pour
ses enfants de penser qu'on ne leur
rendra sans doute jamais le corps entier
de thierry c'est vrai que et de dire
simple d'aller un renvoi au cimetière
trouvé bon de croix se recueillir on n'a
pas cette
cette chance vous êtes on a eu cette
malchance
après cette chance de votre côté c'est
sûr que c'est dur pour eux parce qu'ils
n'ont rien cette fois mais là c'est
d'avoir quelques joueurs défensive a
téléphoné et il n'a pas plus aujourd'hui
mais c'est tout mais c'est difficile de
réaliser qu'il est pas là
thierry saada était marié son épouse
était enceinte au moment de sa
disparition
c'est aussi pour ce petit fils qui vit
aux états unis que les saada sont
aujourd'hui à new york
un chiffre encore l'indemnisation des
victimes entre 4 et 6 milliards de
dollars soit 10 millions de francs en
moyenne par personne avec des disparités
importantes selon les catégories
sociales c'est d'ailleurs un sujet de
polémique assez vif
on en avait déjà parlé ici là on
découvre une image d'un de ses nombreux
rassemblements à la bougie comme l'an
passé qui ont repris depuis quelques
jours ça se passait hier soir à l'ong
island dans la banlieue de new york à
mes côtés bruno des linges et bonsoir
bruno bonsoir nous sommes heureux de
vous accueillir parce que on avait passé
pas mal de temps avec vous l'an dernier
vous êtes français par le passeport mais
un peu new yorkais d'adoption ça fait
une dizaine d'années que vous êtes aux
états unis vous en avait réchappé de
justesse il ya un an puisque vous aviez
quitté les tours quelques minutes avant
leur effondrement
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
que les new-yorkais se pose beaucoup
parce qu'on sent un certain désarroi
al'approche de cette commémoration où
serez vous demain que ferez vous est-ce
que vous allez quitter la ville ou au
contraire participer aux cérémonies où
les suivre je participerai aux
cérémonies je compte venir avec ma femme
et mes employés ici et je pense qu on
déposera tout simplement des fleurs et
puis il ya une chose que j'aimerais
faire c'est retrouver les deux femmes
qu'il y a un an
alors ce que je remontais de cette zone
de guerre et que j'étais comme un
véritable fantôme qui remonte elle à la
ville et que tout mon être réclamait
l'affection du de ceux qui m'entouraient
et que personne n'osait s'approcher de
moi parce que je faisais peur il ya deux
femmes qui sont approchés de moi et qui
m'ont offert un verre d'eau qui m'ont
fait rentrer dans un magasin et qui
m'ont
demander d'utiliser le téléphone pour
que je puisse appeler ceux qui me sont
proches et ça j'aimerais beaucoup les
retrouver un an plus tard j'espère que
ce sera ce sera possible
où en êtes vous vous même je lisais dans
votre dans votre livre par exemple que
pendant très longtemps vous n'avez pas
pu regarder les images de ce 11
septembre
non j'ai d'abord aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas les regarder à la proche du 11
septembre
parce que d'une part je ne veux pas en
permanence vivre dans ce cauchemar
d'autre part pour moi elle ne parle pas
autant que tout ce qui a entouré le 20
septembre et tous seront septembre qui
se prolonge pendant des mois et que j'ai
essayé de décrire dans le livre et ce
sont des hommes des femmes et toutes ces
images finalement ne traduisent pas
toute cette émotion tout ce drame humain
qui s'est prolongée pendant des mois
pour nous tous je me souviens il ya un
an quand on s'était rencontrés vous
faisiez un constat vous disiez cette
ville new york très individualiste s'est
redécouvert avec une solidarité
étonnante entre les gens tendent est-il
un an après ce que ça continue ou est-ce
que ça n'est plus qu'un souvenir
new york reste new york et les habitudes
reviennent
business as usual 'business as usual' et
c'est à sa grandeur je dirais parce que
il y a eu une réaction de fierté dans
tout cela à vouloir absolument apporter
une réponse positive à cette horreur
mais en même temps il ya aussi une
ferveur qui ne disparaît pas et qui a
profondément marqué la ville me
semble-t-il et new york s'est
redécouvert parce que new york a passé
des périodes successives parfois de
dominer par labatt l'appât du gain et il
ya quelque chose de plus maintenant
merci bruno votre livre au world trade
center
quarante septième étage aux éditions
robert laffont merci bruno on évoquer le
désarroi des new yorkais il y a aussi un
débat en ce qui concerne les enfants
faut-il parler et comment faut-il parler
du 11 septembre à l'école beaucoup ont
réfléchi à ce sujet c'est un reportage
de stéphane breitner et olivier robert
comme d'habitude la journée commence par
le salut au drapeau et ce matin la voix
des enfants résonne un peu plus fort le
collège de bocquaine s'apprête à
commémorer les attaques du 11 septembre
un premier anniversaire particulier de
l'école on pouvait voir les tours
jumelles
ici il y a deux cents élèves de 100
témoins directs de la catastrophe pour
cet hommage aux victimes
les plus petits ont pris leur pastel du
rouge et beaucoup de noirs là c'est
quand l'avion est ce que la première
tour il est tous ces gens blessés tous
ces enfants qui avaient besoin dead et
là ce sont les camions de pompiers qui
essayent de maîtriser le feu tu as envie
d'oublier a causé tous ces policiers qui
sont morts en essayant de sauver des
vies
un long silence puis des blessures qui
se roule
[Musique]
parfois je suis terrifié de penser que
cela pourrait se produire un museau mais
le pire c'est qu'on ne sait pas où ça se
passerait alors donc se sent plus en
sécurité nulle part il ça c'est très
effrayé par cette aura demandé aux
écoles d'évoquer la tragédie les
professeurs et de leurs élèves à
surmonter cette douleur qui refait
surface
mais celle qui dirige le collège est
perplexe face à cette initiative ne peut
pas éviter d'en parler mais je me
demande si c'est bon pour les enfants
car maintenant on entend parler d'autres
attentats possible et cela ne fait
qu'entretenir l'angoissent des enfants
face à la mort demain tous les élèves se
réuniront dans le parc de broken juste
en face de ground zero une cérémonie du
souvenir pour les 45 habitants de la
ville qui ont péri dans les décombres du
world trade center
et nous voici sur ce qui est redevenu le
sommet de new york depuis le 11
septembre le vieil empailleur state
building inaugurée en 1931 102 étages
380 mètres de haut
plus l'antenne quinze mille personnes y
travaillent chaque jour et l'immeuble
offre la vue la plus complète sur le sud
de new york wall street où s'élevaient
les deux tours et à droite on la
distingue la statue de la liberté au
loin bonsoir pascal golomer vous êtes
notre correspondant à new york on a vu
qu'il y avait un débat sur le rôle des
écoles il y à un débat aussi sur les
images du 11 septembre faut-il repasser
les images de la destruction des tours
mais ça valait les new-yorkais ont vécu
cette journée tragique du 11 septembre
comme une journée exceptionnelle
ils ont vécu aussi les mois qui ont
suivi comme des mois exceptionnel parce
qu'ils ont su redémarrer ils sont très
fiers de ce redémarrage de ce dynamisme
dans la villa a fait preuve et n'ont pas
forcément envie aujourd'hui de plonger à
nouveau dans les images de destruction
des tours il veut passer à autre chose
bien sûr on verra beaucoup de
témoignages en parle beaucoup les
témoignages des familles de victimes des
survivants mais ils ne veulent pas voir
ces images de destruction des tours qui
s'effondrent qui sont qui sont vraiment
pour eux quelque chose de très dur le
maire lui-même il ya quelques jours et
qui n'avait pas besoin de voir ces
images pour se rendre
compte à quel point cette journée cette
journée est exceptionnel pour new york
et alors ces images de destruction nous
allons les revoir
autant vous prévenir à l'avancé si vous
avez des enfants notamment à vos côtés
nous allons les revoir et nous allons
les vivres à travers les principaux
acteurs du moment george bush notamment
et condoleezza rice
c'est une évocation détiennent leenhardt
les historiens écriront sans doute que
ce matin là le ciel sur manhattan était
bleu et que l'on y voyait à plusieurs
centaines de mètres à la ronde
il est 8 heures 45 le matin du 11
septembre
[Musique]
un boeing 767 en provenance de boston
vient de s'engouffrer dans la tour nord
du world trade center la plus grave
attaque terroriste de l'histoire des
états unis vient de commencer à l'heure
où dans le quartier d'affaires de new
york
les rues sont traditionnellement bondés
[Applaudissements]
les premiers policiers auront tout juste
le temps de faire évacuer les alentours
et les premières équipes de télévision
d'installer leur caméra pour offrir au
monde entier en direct l'arrivée à 900
km heure du vol 175 bourré de kérosène à
cette heure-là le président des états
unis visite une école en floride
j'ai vu le premier avion rentrer dans la
tour
la télé était allumée moi même j'ai été
pilote et je me suis dit le gars aux
commandes n'était vraiment pas doué ça a
dû être un accident terrible
et puis alors que je me concentrais sur
la classe dans laquelle j'étais andrew
card l'un de mes conseillers s'est
approché et m'a chuchoté à l'oreille
un deuxième avion est rentré dans une
tour l'amérique est attaquée
livide george bush se retient sans doute
devant les écoliers rassemblées de
quitter la classe en courant tout au
long de la journée et escortée en
permanence par des appareils militaires
air force one va trimballer le président
de floride en louisiane de louisiane en
alaska
les services secrets refuseront une
bonne partie de la journée que george
bush regagne washington où le danger
s'est déplacé 58 minutes après le crash
du premier avion un appareil d'american
airlines à destination de los angeles
fini sa course à basse altitude dans
l'immeuble du pentagone le symbole de la
puissance militaire américaine
un quatrième boeing dont on ne sera sans
doute jamais s'ils étaient destinés à la
maison blanche ou à l'immeuble du
congrès sera lui précipiter dans un
champ après une bagarre entre les
passagers et les pirates de l'air mais
le pire est encore à venir
nous pensions que l' incendie à les
faire fondre la structure des tours et
que tous les étages situé au dessus de
l'impact de l'appareil s'effondrerait
c'est vraiment tout ce que nous avions
espéré
[Musique]
en 30 minutes l'une après l'autre les
deux tours jumelles fondent
littéralement emportant avec elle les
milliers d'employés et de secouriste
piégés à l'intérieur
il est à peine 11 heures du matin
et il fait déjà nuit sur manhattan
dans les couloirs d'immeubles l'air
chargé de poussières et de cendre
devient vite irrespirable
mais ceux qui s'y sont réfugiés ne
connaissent pas leur bonheur
m
car dehors manhattan n'est plus qu'un
énorme nuage blanc d'où émerge au compte
gouttes des fantômes de poussière
à midi tous les appareils civils se sont
posés dans les aéroports les plus
proches la plus audacieuse des attaques
terroristes jamais imaginé est terminé
il est secouriste commence à découvrir
l'ampleur du drame
plus de 2800 personnes laisseront leur
vie dans les gravats du world trade
center
la première puissance mondiale et
déstabilise quand je suis rentré chez
moi le soir j'ai allumé la télévision et
j'ai entendu en grande-bretagne jouer
notre hymne national est là pour la
première fois j'ai vraiment adoré parce
que pour nous américains
c'était très émouvant à la tombée de la
nuit sous la lumière des projecteurs les
189 victimes de l'attaqué contre le
pentagone sont extraites des décombres
dans les ailes du ministère de la
défense qui n'ont pas été touchés des
centaines de personnes sont déjà au
travail pour venger l'affront fait à
cette amérique qui se pensaient
jusque-là invulnérable
et un an après ici à new york les
travaux ne sont toujours pas terminés
regarder cette tour
cette tour fantôme recouverte d'une
housse noire c'était le siège d'une
grande banque elle a été minée par le
choc on pensait la sauver elle devra
sans doute finalement être démolis alors
ça nous amène à ce qui a changé depuis
le 11 septembre et notamment à ce qui
reste la préoccupation principale des
américains l'économie bonsoir etienne
leenhardt vous êtes notre correspondant
aux états unis depuis trois ans c'est
vrai que l'économie n'a pas retrouvé son
dynamisme des années 90 mais peut-être
que le 11 septembre n'est pas le seul
coupable
oui tous les analystes sont à peu près
le même constat c'est à dire que
l'économie avait déjà commencé à
ralentir avant le 11 septembre de
l'année dernière elle a été affectée
cette économie dans certains secteurs
par le 11 septembre notamment le secteur
du transport aérien par exemple
mais le vrai décrochage de la bourse que
l'on a constatés ici aux etats-unis à
partir du printemps et qui a eu des
répercussions en europe a été provoquée
lui parler grand scandale financier
l'affairé enron la sphère groupe comme
beaucoup plus que par le 11-septembre
lui-même un mot sur les libertés
publiques parce que ce qui a changé ça
c'est un fait aux états unis depuis le
11 septembre c'est que l'intervention de
l'état est beaucoup plus importante
notamment en matière de sécurité
est ce qu'on peut dire de façon un peu
abrupte que les libertés publiques ont
été ont été atteintes aux états unis
depuis ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'au
nom de la lutte contre le terrorisme le
gouvernement bush a pris certaines
mesures plus ou moins restrictive
certaines mesures étaient avons eu un
effet de rééquilibrage en quelque sorte
on adore on avait coutume de dire avant
le 11 septembre qu'on pouvait prendre
l'avion aux états unis en montrant
simplement sa carte de gymnaste club et
pas forcément une pièce d'identité
et bien cela changeait évidemment il ya
une nouvelle loi qui a été mise en place
la loi patriote qui a autorisé les
contrôles d'identité qui autorise les
écoutes téléphoniques par exemple ce qui
n'existait pas aux états unis juste ici
et puis il ya un autre domaine qui lui
est beaucoup plus polémique c'est que
juste après le 11 septembre il ya eu des
centaines et des centaines
d'arrestations toujours au nom de cette
même lutte contre le terrorisme de
personnes qui ont été détenus au secret
qui n'ont pu consulter d'avocats qui
parfois ont été déportés hélas beaucoup
d'associations considère que ce sont des
mesures qui sont indignes d'une grande
démocratie à un mot enfin de l'anthrax
etienne parce qu'on avait beaucoup parlé
il ya tout de même eu cinq morts une
psychose collective énorme est ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
responsables
non on ne sait toujours pas la psychose
s'est relativement apaisé mais vous avez
raison de dire qu'elle a été au moins
aussi importante que la psychose des
attentats même si elle a fait
heureusement moins
victime l'enquète s'est recentré ici aux
etats-unis sur le domaine scientifique
sur les chercheurs qui ont accès à ces
fameux souches de bacille du charbon
mais on n'en sait toujours pas plus
merci etienne alors on l'a vu dans les
reportages et puis je vous le disais au
début de cette édition spéciale la
menace terroriste on sent bien et
toujours là rappelons le le niveau d'
alerte a été élevée au niveau 4 presque
le niveau le plus élevé et puis
dictionnaire a été placé en lieu sûr à
l'instant de george bush qui s'exprimait
à l'ambassade d'afghanistan a indiqué
que ces menaces
donc des menaces que c'était dévoilé par
le fbi elle devait être prise très au
sérieux
elle nous rappelle la forme des menaces
émises avant les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 a dit le président
américain
ce matin les télévisions américaines ont
tout mentionner la fermeture des
ambassades américaines dans certains
pays d'asie pour des raisons de sécurité
et puis elles sont revenus aussi sur ce
nouveau document qui émanerait d'al
qaïda nous en avons parlé hier voici
maintenant le détail il est commenté par
martine laroche-joubert
ce n'est qu'une voie assourdi mêlés à
des chants religieux
mais les mots sont claires d'abord des
félicitations pour les kamikazes des
attentats du 11-septembre et plus
spécialement pour les trois pilotes qui
ont précipité les avions sur les tours
du world trade center et sur le
pentagone
ils ont purifié la nation islamique
poursuit la voix sans visage attribué à
oussama ben laden
c'est sans doute sa voix elle est plutôt
linéaire puisqu'il ne ne produisent pas
en direct
donc c'est ce qui explique un peu cette
voie bourreuse et linéaire mais il va
garder à mon avis sa parution sur les
écrans pour un événement majeur tel
celui d' en septembre deuxième document
diffusé par la chaîne qatarie al jazira
un des kamikazes du 11-septembre à
saoudien avait enregistré avant sa mort
un testament il fait l'éloge de ben
laden
autre vidéo des kamikazes présentés
comme des militants du réseau al-qaïda
consultent des manuels d'aviation et des
cartes d'aériennes montrant le pentagone
à washington
l'une des cibles attaqués le 11
septembre il a voulu aussi mobilisé ses
troupes en montrant qu'il est toujours
là et toujours menaçants et en montrant
ses cartes et ses plans ça veut dire
qu'ils envisagent d'autres attaques
quoi qu'il en soit avec ses doigts surgi
de nulle part l'objectif est atteint
revenir sur le devant de la scène à la
veille du 11 septembre à l'occasion de
cette édition spéciale nous avons voulu
faire le point sur la lutte contre les
circuits financiers d'al qaïda
souvenez-vous juste après les attentats
de george bush avait rendu publique la
liste de présumés banquier du terrorisme
eh bien nous avons retrouvé l'un de ces
hommes qui étaient placés en tête de
liste il vit paisiblement en suisse
c'est une enquête d'olivier caroff c'est
moi pièce où je suis toujours bienvenu
chez albert your bird ou plutôt ahmed
your bird
c'est ainsi qu'il se fait appeler depuis
sa conversion à l'islam il ya 30 ans à
chaque visiteur cet ancien journaliste
suisse commence par montrer sa galerie
de souvenirs fed met des nazis martin
bourque et des dirigeants islamistes
ces fortes en l'espace à celle il faut
pas aussi un peu une provocation en haut
c'est ayatollah khomeini adolf hitler
ensuite celle là ben laden avec lequel
je ne sympathise pas beaucoup qui
sourient pas de sympathie pour ben laden
les états unis pensent le contraire
un médium beurre ferait partie du réseau
financier d'oussama ben laden
son nom figure sur la liste noire du
terrorisme dressé par les américains
motif
avec des hommes d'affaires arabes ahmed
you were a fondé la banque al taqwa un
établissement installé en suisse à
lugano
officiellement pour faire de l'aide au
développement la banque attaque hu avait
un capital d'à peu près 50 millions de
dollars ce qui est pas beaucoup pour une
banque
et puis on avait nous un sorte circuit
d'1 2 3 millions par an n'est ce pas où
on finançait des projets des projets
terroristes
l'administration bush en est convaincu
novembre 2001 le président américain
demande le gel partout dans le monde des
avoirs dalta coire et ses dirigeants
pour un mètre cube heures cela n'a pas
changé grand chose il peut toujours
aller à sa banque et retirer de l'argent
comme n'importe qui son comptable bien
été bloqué en novembre mais depuis tout
s'est arrangé totalement il n'y a aucun
problème depuis décembre de l'année
dernière il n'y a plus aucun problème on
a levé sa durée peut-être une semaine
les américains n'ont pas fourni de
preuves
la justice suisse n'a rien pu faire où
ça la semaine dernière un médiateur a
reçu un courrier un questionnaire à
remplir pour être éventuellement retiré
de la liste
il ne leur enverra pas rester sur cette
liste dit il est un homme voilà retour à
new york donc juste devant le grand zero
où s'élevaient les deux tours alors le
passé et le présent se télescopent d'une
certaine manière car l'horizon de la
lutte antiterroriste américaine s'étend
maintenant à l'irak
la perspective d'une opération militaire
contre saddam hussein est maintenant
clairement énoncé donald rumsfeld a
rappelé hier encore le ministre de la
défense américain bagdad est accusé de
soutenir le terrorisme et de développer
des armes de destruction massive
l'armée américaine se dit prête à
frapper et veut le faire savoir en
caroline du nord
en portage etienne leenhardt aaron
diamond en plein été sur les côtes de
caroline du nord la température descend
rarement en dessous des 35 degrés et
c'est pourtant avec un bel entrain que
les soldats de la seconde division des
marines se répètent leurs fondamentaux
quand le jeune terrain de jeu des
troupes d'assaut de l'armée américaine
on y fait la guerre pour de faux mais on
s'y prépare pour de vrai et de façon
très réaliste intervenir où que ce soit
dans le monde avec dans la tête de tous
ces hommes le sentiment profond que la
lutte contre le terrorisme les mènera
bien vite dans des contrées nouvelle
l'irak
je sais pas trop quoi en penser mais
j'aimerais bien y aller m'occuper de ça
et qu'on en finisse une bonne fois
qu'est d'un lointain
vous savez on est déjà allé là bas
franchement on peut y retourner
évidemment le décor ne ressemble pas
franchement à une ville irakienne et la
dispersion de cette pseudo manifestation
un côté un peu surréel
mais le moral des troupes est au plus
haut et n'allez pas importuner le
général en lui rappelant qu'un an après
le début de l'opération en afghanistan
ces marines n'ont toujours pas trouvé de
l'aide qu'il soit mort ou vivant ça n'a
pas d'importance qui compte c'est que
nous restions vigilants et qu'ils
comprennent que dès qu'il sort clash est
du trou toute la puissance de notre
grand pays valeur flambe et l'ambiance
guerrière et revancharde qui a cours aux
états unis depuis bientôt un an a
entraîné une véritable explosion à la
hausse du budget de la défense
ces hommes le savent les moyens les plus
sophistiqués seront mises à leur
disposition pour qu'un jour ou l'autre
quelque part dans le monde
l'humiliation ressentie par l'amérique
le 11 septembre de l'année dernière soit
enfin réparé
bonsoir tom bishop vous êtes directeur
du centre de civilisation française à
l'université de new york
ce projet d'intervention américain est
très discutée en europe on y voit le
signe peut-être que les états unis
n'écoute plus personne
juste avant d'en parler avec vous on
s'est demandé ce qu'en pensaient les new
yorkais ici à quelques heures des
cérémonies réactions recueillies à la
volée par claude son père édouard perrin
je pense que saddam hussein est un
effroyable étape il accumule des armes
de destruction massive et je crois qu'il
est grand temps m'est arrivé
saddam représente un danger je pense
qu'il faut s'en occuper
moi je méprise monsieur bush il n'a pas
servi sens politique
amina je ne peux pas envoyer de
montpellier moi je suis absolument
contre la guerre avec l'irak pense pas
que la guerre soit qu'une solution mais
il faut bien en trouver une solution je
pense que saddam devrait permettre aux
inspecteurs de voir ces stocks n'a rien
à cacher on aurait pouvoir tout vérifier
c'est important pour mieux de
correctement anticipé les événements est
d'essayer d'empêcher de nouvelles
attaques comme le 11 mai le président
bush doit nous expliquer les raisons
d'une éventuelle guerre les partager
avec nous les gens doivent comprendre
pourquoi il faut lutter contre saddam
hussein quel danger
il représente monsieur ne respecte pas
les résolutions de l'onu
la force est la seule solution tom
bishop donc vous avez un pied en france
un pied aux etats-unis est-ce que vous
pensez que le 11 septembre a provoqué un
raidissement aux états unis un
changement d'attitude dans le sens de
l'unilatéralisme bien oui absolument
surtout dans les mois qui ont suivi pas
tout de suite parce que la première
réaction de washington s'était de
chercher de rechercher activement le
soutien de tous deux des alliés des amis
et
merritt l'a eu elle a eu ce soutien par
la suite washington s'est séparé de plus
en plus et je crois qu'on ne peut pas
parler autrement que dans neuilly
unilatéralisme aujourd'hui dans
l'attitude de washington qui est très
troublante pour beaucoup de gens ici en
france on parle beaucoup en cette
rentrée de la montée de l'anti
américanisme et c'est un peu paradoxal
alors que les etats-unis ont été très
douloureusement frappé est ce que vous
vous y voyez la conséquence de cet
unilatéralisme américains ou est-ce que
vous pensez que la fosse est en train de
se creuser entre les deux peuples
non moi je crois que yahia de l'antienne
américanisme endémique en europe mais là
c'est autre chose je crois qu'il ya une
réaction contre des contre une politique
que l'europe trouve pas du tout à son
goût et qu'elle critique à mon art en ce
qui me concerne à juste titre et donc il
ya certainement un écart qui se creuse
oui est ce que les américains suivent
leur président dans cette politique
d'une présence très affirmée et cet
unilatéralisme et bien ou comment savoir
d un raidissement là aussi de la part de
des américains un sondage ce dernier
week end a montré que l'amérique ne suis
plus aveuglément tout ce que dit
washington que notamment l'idée
d'attaquer un pays sans avoir été
attaquées ne plaît pas beaucoup
enfin en tout cas au pao au plus de la
moitié des gens c'est des gens pour un
jean ça pourrait ralentir washi comme ce
que j'espère merci beaucoup tom bishop
d'avoir été avec nous ainsi s'achève
cette édition spéciale rappelons quand
même à ce propos que jeudi il y aura un
discours très attendu de george bush
devant les nations unies à propos de
cette affaire irakiennes d'ici là bien
sûr vous le savez demain ce seront les
cérémonies de commémoration du 11
septembre à suivre en direct sur notre
antenne au tour de daniel bilalian et
détiennent leenhardt ici à new york
elles démarreront à 14h45 heure
française à l'heure précise où le
premier avion a percuté les tours
on se quitte avec cette vue de manhattan
prise de l'autre côté de l'hudson river
depuis le new-jersey à ce fantastique
paysage de béton et de verre mais qui ne
compte plus désormais ces deux fameuses
tours du world trade center
abou béatrice et avant de refermer ce
journal nous nous retrouvons pour un
dernier point sur les inondations qui
ont ravagé le sud est de la france
le bilan des victimes évolue d'heure en
heure il s'est alourdi depuis le début
de ce journal il sera en ce moment de 26
morts et douze disparus le point avec
christelle bertrand un peu partout la
décrue s'amorce plus ou moins vite la
petite commune d'aramon à quelques
kilomètres de nîmes a payé un lourd
tribut aux inondations
quatre corps sans vie ont été retrouvés
ici c'est une digue qui a cédé sous la
force de la creuse par endroits l'eau
est montée jusqu'à 5 mètres
[Musique]
les habitants commencent à regagner
leurs maisons soulagés mais en colère je
comprends pas c'est que c'est la masse
d'eau qui était derrière la digue aurait
dû faire en sorte qu'elle est que les
gens bien informés ou habilité nous nous
sommes tous ces informations la
circulation ferroviaire reprend
lentement sauf sur la ligne nîmes alès
ou la réparation de ce viaduc devrait
demander un mois de travaux ce soir dans
le sud-est
cinquante mille foyers sont encore
privés d'électricité de téléphone et de
gaz si les autoroutes sont rouvertes les
nationales et départementales sont
encore difficilement praticables après
trente six heures d'orage et
d'inondations le sud-est offre un
paysage de d'élus dans le gard il est
tombé autant de pluie depuis dimanche
quand un an à paris ce soir
le bilan s'alourdit encore pour
l'instant on dénombre 26 morts et douze
disparus et précisément direct d'aramon
nous vous retrouvons nathalie jour dans
deux nouveaux corps ont été donc
retrouver dans ce petit village après la
rupture de la digue la nuit dernière et
ce qu'on s'attend à de nouvelles
victimes
oui tout à fait ce n'est pas à exclure
malheureusement les pompiers ont tant
fait repêcher 11 corps à rames ans
aujourd'hui dont six corps de femme
il ya également quatre personnes
toujours disparues et il risque d'en
trouver on risque encore d'en trouver
d'autres parce que l'eau continue de
descendre ici on avait à peu près 2 m
encore cet après midi
l'eau descend donc certaines zones va
devenir un peu plus accessible aux
pompiers qui vont pouvoir procéder à des
interventions plus ciblées donc
malheureusement le bilan n'est que
provisoire 11 morts à aramon il y a
également une trentaine de personnes que
les pompiers cherchent à localiser les
pompiers qui appelle d'ailleurs tous
ceux qui ne se sont pas signalés en
mairie à le faire rapidement pour
effectuer une sorte de une sorte de
recensement après la rupture de la digue
les pompiers qui vont travailler donc
toute la nuit il y a également une
cellule de soutien psychologique qui va
fonctionner qui va rester ouvertes toute
la nuit savez ici on assister à des
grands élans de solidarité de la part de
la population qui a sillonné embarque
les rues inondées du village pour
apporter un peu d'eau un peu de
nourriture à ceux qui sont restés
bloqués chez eux la solidarité s'exprime
tellement ici il n'y a pas eu besoin de
créer de structures spéciales
d'hébergement en fait les gens vont
s'aider les uns les autres ceux qui
n'ont pas de toit ce soir vont pouvoir
dormir soit chez des voisins des amis ou
de la famille merci de ces précisions
nathalie jourdan encore une information
mais celles ci ne nous parvient de
russie à moscou un incendie s'est
déclaré dans un centre de physique
nucléaire où il y aurait huit réacteurs
nucléaires
mais pour l'instant au nul ne peut dire
quelle est l'importance de l'incendié et
les risques éventuels
nous reviendrons évidemment sur cette
information dans nos autres jose
journaux ainsi ce termine ce journal je
vous remercie votre attention dans un
instant la météo présentée par sophie
davant 1h08 le journal de la nuit jean
claude renault demain dans les 4 vérités
pour se saborde recevra en direct de new
york george soros le financier
international à 13 heures daniel
bilalian batteur david pujadas
excellente soirée sur france 2
[Musique]
oh